on va provoquer des courts-circuits et
Diane Klein c'est le titre de votre
essai chez Gallimard on connaît votre
goût pour les sujets apparemment sans
lien entre la physique et la philosophie
par exemple la vie des idées nous
dites-vous mérite qu'on la décloisonne
regardez c'est dans le sujet de Maïté
Frémont et puis on en parle ensemble
juste après
si on vous invite Etienne Klein c'est
parce que vous incontournable
vulgarisateur scientifique provoquer une
nouvelle fois des étincelles voir des
coups de foudre donc court-circuit votre
nouvelle essai vous natomisez pas les
murs qui séparent certaines disciplines
mais vous créez des passerelles entre
les sciences dures et les sciences
humaines un livre court 205 pages qui
s'ouvrent avec l'histoire de votre frère
votre antiparticule allergique aux
équations dès qu'on dit que deux choses
sont absolument différentes on ne peut
pas s'empêcher de tenter de les
hiérarchiser on dit que a n'est pas du
tout la même chose que B et la question
qui vient c'est est-ce que A est plus
grand que B ou meilleur que B ou est-ce
que c'est l'inverse et ça aboutit à une
hiérarchie dans le spectre
d'intelligence qui a des effets sur la
façon dont on oriente les cerveaux par
exemple si vous êtes soi-disant
intelligent on va vous conseiller de
devenir intellectuel ou scientifique et
si vous n'êtes pas on va vous demander
de faire une soit professionnel physique
et philosophie réalité et imagination
hasard et destin dans ces 10 chapitres
vous associez des éléments souvent
séparés dans la vie des idées le binôme
le plus atypique pour aborder la notion
du temps le voici celui de vos deux
idoles accrochées sur le mur de votre
chambre d'adolescent Einstein d'un côté
les Rolling Stones de l'autre
Etienne Klein bien difficile de vous
définir vous n'êtes ni physicien ni
philosophe vous vous posez là où se
trouve la question du langage dites-vous
votre credo c'est d'exprimer avec des
mots ce que les physiciens disent avec
des équations et des expériences grâce à
vos ouvrages les sciences deviennent un
peu plus simples même pour ceux qui n'y
connaissent rien les sciences pour les
nuls quitte à créer des polémiques l'été
dernier vous postez sur les réseaux
sociaux une photo d'un chorizo avec pour
les jambes photos de l'étoile la plus
proche du Soleil un canular connu chez
les scientifiques pris pour une vérité
pour des milliers d'internautes alors
une question ce soir Étienne Klein
casser les barrières entre les
disciplines dès le plus jeune âge
permettrait-il de passer un peu moins
pour des andouilles
réponse c'était le clan en fait dans ce
livre je ne parle pas
d'interdisciplinarité je parle plutôt de
cohérence parce que l'interdiscipérité
qui suppose qu'on va mélanger les
disciplines
en rigueur par exemple moi non je pense
qu'il y a des questions
se rapprocher voir ce que ça donne
regardez les éléments de langage par
exemple il y a des mots communs à
plusieurs disciplines est-ce qu'ils ont
le même sens dans toutes les disciplines
exemple le temps le temps moi j'ai
travaillé pendant des années sur le
temps avec des collègues les physiciens
parlent du temps les philosophes parlent
du temps donc il y a une première
question quand on a fait ce constat
c'est lorsqu'elle de la même manière
est-ce qu'il parle de la même chose si
la réponse à cette question est non il
parle de choses différentes il faudrait
les nommer par deux mots différents et
si parlent de la même chose est-ce que
ils en disent les mêmes choses et la
réponse est clairement NON et donc à qui
doit-on accorder du crédit dès lors que
toutes les thèses cohabitent et c'est ce
genre de rencontre qui à mon avis peut
aider chacune des disciplines à
progresser notamment dans la façon
qu'elle a de s'expliquer pour le grand
public
et physique par exemple quel autre
exemple vous pourriez nous donner de
couple de disciplines qui ont intérêt à
se regarder pas forcément à se mélanger
mais par exemple on pense à la science
de l'inconscient certains diront que
c'est pas une science en tout cas la
psychologie et peut-être les sciences
cognitives là il y a un couple qui fait
oui
des instruments de physique les
neurosciences pour être villes le
cerveau par exemple utilise des
instruments quand il est mis au point
par des physiciens donc il y a déjà un
apport disons techniques ensuite il y a
est-ce que la physique par exemple peut
aider à comprendre la vie où est-ce que
les lois de la biologie bénéfiques
bénéficient d'une sorte
d'extraterritorialité par rapport aux
lois physiques est-ce que les lois
biologiques s'il y en a s'ajoutent aux
lois physiques ou est-ce qu'elles sont
in émanation à une certaine échelle des
lois qui existent un niveau plus profond
dans le domaine de la physique donc se
parler entre disciplines pour clarifier
aussi à mon avis c'est d'abord pour de
reconnaître pas forcément pour
collaborer et pour se connaître savoir
de quoi on parle quels sont les objets
d'études comparer les méthodologies
parce que toutes les sciences ne
travaillent pas la même façon un
sociologue ne travaille pas comme un
physicien théoricien qui ne travaille
pas comme un biologiste et donc c'est
déjà comprendre tout cela et ensuite
voir si certaines questions bien posées
réclament pour être traitées qu'on
sollicite plusieurs disciplines il
s'agit pas des rassembler pour le
plaisir de les rassembler il s'agit pas
de provoquer un mélange des genres pour
faire genre il s'agit de poser une
question bien précise et ensuite de voir
quelles sont les disciplines qui peuvent
t'aider à y répondre des passerelles
mais pas forcément la grande bouillie
c'est très
clairs votre premier chapitre vous le
consacrez à Pascal c'est votre frère
décédé il y a 2 ans et demi virtuose de
la clé à molette et du fer à souder il
aimait avant tout réparer penser avec
ses mains il a été un peu brisé
notamment par l'école personne ne lui
avait dit qu'Einstein était aussi
bricoleur notamment pas moi je le
regrette il avait non plus que moi il
est moyen un an et demi et il avait
besoin de d'apprendre par corps pas en
regardant des équations il était
mal à l'aise avec les raisonnements
abstraits il les mettent touchés pour
comprendre d'ailleurs avant de réparer
des choses il en a beaucoup cassé
notamment mes jouets et fabriquer pour
comprendre comment
on a fabriqué un avion ensemble sous ses
ordres j'étais incapable dans ce domaine
de prendre des initiatives mais il avait
besoin oui de démonter les objets pour
les construire et il pouvait comprendre
le fonctionnement de moteur de toutes
sortes sont sans comprendre les
équations physiques qui permettent de
comprendre le fonctionnement il pouvait
comprendre n'empêche que cette
intelligence manuelle n'a pas été
reconnu c'est typiquement français vous
pensez à l'heure où Emmanuel Macron
essaye de relancer le chantier du lycée
professionnel
mais il me semble que dans d'autres pays
que je connais un peu la Suisse
l'Allemagne l'Angleterre ça fonctionne
pas du tout comme ça pourquoi ça je sais
pas je pense que qu'est-ce qu'on a nous
avec le manuel le fer comme la capacité
à accéder à l'abstraction
alors qu'il y a une intelligence du
corps il y a une intelligence des mains
d'ailleurs toute ma intelligente est
pilotée par un esprit les guides
d'autres montagnes dont je parle ou les
facteurs d'orgue sont des gens qui ont
une intelligence tout à fait évidente
quand on les voit manipuler les
instruments qui les passionnent non j'ai
l'impression que que l'abstraction est
la mesure suprême de l'intelligence
qu'on soit d'ailleurs littéraire ou
scientifique il faut planer ça c'est le
symptôme que on pense bien mais je pense
que l'intelligence elle est plutôt
répartie selon un spectre continue qu'on
a tort de vouloir hiérarchiser encore
cette question de la hiérarchie Michel
Serres donc au cœur de cet ouvrage
philosophe des sciences vous inscrivez
dans dans ses pas grand vulgarisateur
aussi comme vous mais qui en même temps
connaissait l'impasse de la
vulgarisation toujours un trompe l'oeil
il a vulgarisation qui n'atteint pas son
but oui oui moi c'est le covid
l'expérience du covid qui m'a que ce que
croit je croyais être un succès la
vulgarisation en fait
quand je dis cela je biaise mon jugement
c'est à dire que la vulgarisation ça
marche auprès de ceux aux pretty ça
marche voilà qui s'intéresse qui se
délivre qui pose des questions ou bien
ces étudiants qu'on rencontre qui nous
disent qu'ils ont choisi de faire des
sciences parce qu'ils ont lu adolescents
un livre de Michel Serres ou du Berry
qu'est-ce qu'on a raté pendant le covid
alors qu'on a voulu expliquer en mettant
énormément d'épidémiologie sur les
plateaux pour que finalement le
complotisme les fake news explosent moi
je pense qu'on a vu l'occasion
historique de faire de la pédagogie
scientifique en disant voilà s'agissant
des traitements ce qu'est un essai en
double aveugle jour après jour parce que
les gens étaient inquiets ils avaient du
temps à passer devant la télévision il
voulait comprendre et on pouvait leur
expliquer ce que nous savions est-ce que
nous savions de pas savoir
c'est entre la science et la recherche
et puis surtout moi j'aurais aimé
entendre des gens sur les plateaux qui
disent nous nous savons que et nous nous
demandons si
c'est à dire qu'il montre que la science
est une entreprise collective et parfois
il faut dire nous ne savons pas c'est
parce que c'est pas parce que nous
disons que nous ne savons pas que nous
sommes moins savants
je ne sais pas on va dire c'est pas un
bon savant et on va le faire et qu'il
soit remplacé médiatiquement par
quelqu'un qui a réponse à tout et qui ne
doute jamais un mot sur un très joli
passage sur la joie chez Michel Serres
ce paradoxe de la joie malgré la
violence malgré la misère du monde
Michel Serres joyeux malgré tout oui
qui a connu d'ailleurs Michel Zack
s'appelait Clément Rosset Clément il y a
quelques années qui parlait du paradoxe
de la joie en disant la joie c'est la
force majeure on n'est pas joyeux parce
qu'on a des raisons d'être joyeux on est
joyeux au contraire prendre parce qu'on
a conscience du tragique
il me semble que Michel serre incarnait
cette sorte de paradoxe il était
toujours de bonne humeur toujours
qu'il a essayé de convertir
philosophiquement dans l'idée dominance
avec l'idée que l'humanité va finalement
lentement progresser et peut-être se
débarrasser de la violence et depuis que
ce livre le déluge informationnel est
toujours voulu expliquer comment ça
marchait aujourd'hui on utilise des
smartphones sans même se poser la
question ça reste inaccessible il l'a
connu ce déluge informationnel et
d'ailleurs au début il était très
enthousiaste il pensait que le numérique
les smartphones par exemple allaient
nous permettre d'avoir une encyclopédie
portative et puis il a vu qu'en effet
dans les mêmes canaux de communication
circulent des connaissances mais aussi
des croyances des commentaires beaucoup
de commentaires des avis des fake news
tout ça se mélange les statues
respectives de ces différents éléments
qui sont différents ont tendance à
s'amalgamer et ça je sais qu'à la fin de
la ville a donné une dernière interview
à philosophie une gazine sur ce sujet il
était plutôt
plutôt pessimiste et puis il y a
l'intelligence artificielle l'IA qui
commence à remplacer les journalistes
les comptables les secrétaires et j'en
passe les étudiants même qui recouvrent
à chat Tipiti pour leur exposé les
algorithmes ils vont détrôner à votre
avis notre cerveau
à mon avis ça dépend encore de nous
c'est d'ailleurs finalement plus que les
machines parlent comme nous en langage
naturel parfois elles écrivent mieux que
nous des dissertations des articles quel
rôle devons-nous avoir dans l'expression
de notre parole qu'est-ce que c'est que
une parole authentiquement humaine par
rapport à une machine comme tchadibi je
sais pas si vous avez déjà lu des
dissertations de tchat c'est lisse il y
a pas d'idées fulgurante il y a pas
d'invention de
concepti raconte des choses qui ont déjà
été racontées par les données qui l'ont
été livrées pour pour s'éduquer lui-même
et donc les capacités de d'esprit
critique d'invention de concept ça reste
une démonstration
le mot intelligence dans l'intelligence
artificielle quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle c'est le mot
anglais intelligence qui est la gestion
de données le traitement de la formation
l'intelligence au sens français du terme
c'est aussi la capacité à poser des
questions contre factuelles c'est
l'esprit critique donc on a mal nommé en
fait oui les choses donc pour l'instant
l'intelligence artificielle est
extrêmement bête ça va poser quand même
des questions existentielles on est armé
à votre avis je pense qu'il est temps de
vraiment réfléchir à ce qu'on veut voilà
il y a un paradoxe qui avait été nommé
par Monsieur qui s'appelle moravvec dans
les années 1990 qui disait en gros plus
une tâche est facile à utiliser par un
humain plus elle sera difficile à
exécuter par une machine ou un robot il
donne l'exemple de coiffeur un coiffeur
pour l'instant les coiffeurs ne sont pas
menacés par les robots ils peuvent les
robots peuvent coiffer enfin mettre la
boule à zéro mais pas faire une coupe
harmonieuse et il donnait l'exemple de
la reconnaissance faciale et là il s'est
trompé les machines font la
reconnaissance faciale de façon très
efficace et donc la question est quels
sont les décisions que nous acceptons de
déléguer à des machines quelles sont les
tâches que nous acceptons à déléguer à
des robots c'est urgence pour qu'on
laisse le débat au niveau mondial merci
beaucoup on s'appelle court-circuit au
pluriel ça se picore puisque les
chapitres sont indépendants les uns des
autres ce qui aiment les Rolling Stones
et Albert Einstein c'est une pierre
Stone c'est des pierres et voilà un
court-circuit de plus c'est chez
Gallimard et c'est pass